the agenda is said hello everyone I'm
Brent Goff in Berlin to date on this
show how much should you be paid now the
bosses of the digital economy often say
zero today getting something for nothing
aren't you glad you got out a bit it's
time to talk their creative educated and
unpaid the new economies new poor a
workforce expected to give their time
and effort for peanuts in return today
we ask when will something gift well
who's afraid of fracking a revolution in
the oil and natural gas industry is
underway and the Germans are scared
their fears are not unfounded fracking
can be dangerous to the environment and
to people but some say safety is
possible so why is Berlin frozen on
fracking and remember the scenes from
Star Trek the captain wants a martini
and he simply tells the computer to make
one well we are closer to being captain
kirk than ever before a revolution in
manufacturing thanks to 3d printers even
guns can now be made into comfort of
your own home you see it right there but
what on earth that is does this mean for
keeping the peace and for keeping people
employ why I've invited three people
today to talk argue and pry apart these
headlines my first guest is on the
frontier of 3d printing technology he
leads workshops right here in Berlin on
using 3d printers and he says this
technology is not assuring in a new
industrial revolution I'm happy to
welcome to the show Brom de fries he is
a 3d printer engineer brom you gotta
explain yourself hear you say you know
we can print at home we don't even need
a manufacturer anymore so how can you
say this is not a revolution it is a
revolution but it's often described as a
revolution that's going to replace
everything as when it comes to
manufacturing but I say it's going to
add up to all the other things that we
have been doing until now so I don't
think it will replace metal machining or
the martini factory okay at the martini
Fatiha we're going to talk about getting
that martini on the Starship Enterprise
in just a second good to have you on the
show bro my second guest says that
fracking is simply too dangerous and
should be forbidden here in Germany I'm
happy to welcome to the show Oliver
Krisher he is a member of Germany's
Parliament and he is the Green Party's
go-to man on all fracking issues Oliver
the Americans are fracking Poland is
fracking what do you know that they
don't know everything it's think it's
not a game changer in Germany it's
another gauge chamber even in whole
Europe also not in Poland because the
reserves off the network of shale gas
are very low in Germany and we have
decided in Germany to go to one hundred
percent renewables that's our way of
future energy supply and to fracking of
the new technology with many many risk
for groundwater for all these things and
I think it will no good solution for
Germany all right we're going to we're
going to talk about the people who say
it is a solution I'm in just a moment
glad you can be on the show my next
guest wakes up every day and searches
for the best talent in the tech industry
and he admits that not everyone gets
paid for their work I'm happy to welcome
to the show Jeremy del do GC he is a
Silicon Valley tech recruiter based here
in Berlin right Jeremy yeah is there an
accepted code in the digital economy
that says it's okay to exploit this this
large young talent pool I mean should
they work for no pay and just get used
to it no I don't I don't feel there is
an accepted coat and short there are
just too many positions there are too
many jobs opportunities open to the
youth of today in the digital economy
and there is too much need for talents
in the digital economy so I don't feel
there was a coke matter you mean the
supply is greater than the demand
regular solutely all right all right i
mean that is one argument i have to
admit that i was shocked when we began
researching
just how many people are expected to
work for free in the digital economy a
survey in Australia found that forty
percent of interns in the creative
industries advertising social media PR
felt that they had been exploited more
than seventy-five percent said that they
never received a dime for their work now
all kinds of Internet companies tell
young people that its experience that
matters most now come work for us build
up your resume but don't expect to be
paid that's fine if your wallet is
already fat but for the lower and the
middle class it's tantamount to another
great wall in the new economy a wall
between the haves and the have-nots the
digital economy has the potential to
create jobs while some economies
flounder in recession much of the new
economy is based on freelance workers
for growing numbers of people going to
work doesn't involve sitting in an
office a laptop and an internet
connection is all they need sitting in a
cafe it's possible to write articles
edit videos and upload music but this
work is often badly paid or not paid at
all
as old industries get replaced by new
Internet companies is there enough work
to go around are we swapping real jobs
for unpaid labor I mean is that what is
happening now Jeremy is you've got these
these high-tech companies Internet
companies I mean they are making lots of
money right now are they doing it on the
backs of digital serfs I mean cheap
labor well I can anybody speak for what
I've seen and I know I have heard some
absolute horror stories before
especially of some of them larger more
established internet companies that do
make people work either from home or
on-site for 12 hours a day with very
little or no pay so it does happen but a
lot of the lot of my experience is
working with smaller startups for
example with very little capital behind
them and these companies need to bring
on talent for you know as cheap as
possible basically and they do genuinely
provide an atmosphere in which people
can flourish where they can you know
there they can do an internship and they
can move into more senior positions into
a full-time position later on down the
line I think I think I think most people
would agree with you that with the
startup company they could understand
they want to bring in interns you know
they have their startup capital but
that's it I mean it's going to be a
while before they actually turn a profit
but what about established companies
that have a strong bottom line how do
they justify having people come in for
internships working and not paying them
anything I mean you can't really you
can't justify that if you're bringing
people in if you have good ethics and
you bring people in you pay them and you
provide them a platform in which to in
which to flourish I mean there are
plenty of jobs available and as I said
before very even bigger companies very
high demand and very low supply mm-hmm
but if they're doing this now i don't i
don't think i think that's terribly
wrong and i have heard horror stories
before but they've only been far and few
between in my experience Oh give us an
example of a horror story well I mean
recently a CEO in Germany came up to me
and you know boasted how easy it was for
him to bring interns on interns in and
how cheap it was for him to do so and
how that
a large percentage workforce what were
just interns and I've also heard stories
from big companies in Berlin there you
know again they do the same thing they
exploit they exploit youngsters and make
them work ridiculous hours for very
little what's the policy at your company
on our company well we're very small
company but we hire two interns we have
I to intern so far one we you know we
paid them both very well friend turns
one we turned into a full-time position
within three months and then the next
one we're about to do as well turn into
a full-time position so can an intern
work for you and expect to be hired yes
absolutely I mean 100 set records so far
so I think that's very possible yeah I
mean true but your office here is very
new though right absolutely right but
you know for us I mean we know
especially in the recruitment world we
know it's difficult to find people who
have experienced in digital
entertainment so it's hard to hire
experienced people and also I'd rather
mold people so it's better for us to
hire interns Mulder mins the company and
then give them the opportunity to
flourish I gotta ask you something about
your company I was looking at your
website earlier today your website has
this page where it lists the values of
the company absolutely and it lists 44
values yes and what you're interesting I
mean creativity being cool being
committed to your job being green yeah
not once on the website though is fair
pay listed as a value of your company
hmm I mean I believe that people do get
paid very fairly in our company I mean I
know how much our interns get paid and I
feel that everyone's treated very fairly
I've never heard any gripes before but
maybe that's something we should look at
it yeah isn't it part of the industry
though Jeremy that there is this push
towards the bottom I mean we you know we
talk we've got interns here as well I
mean I talked to people in journalism
and advertising social media and the
talk is always there paid the bare
minimum and expected to perform you know
one hundred and fifty percent does it
that come out of the nature of the
internet where everything appears to be
free mmm I don't know I mean I
thing is not free internet right I mean
labor is treated that way right now
isn't it I I don't know I think there's
too much I mean I think that senior
professionals let's move on to senior
people in the industry get paid very
fairly considering their skill sets and
where they live and obviously depends
entirely on locations but I think there
is a good opportunity for young people
to move up into senior positions very
very quickly and I think for a lot of
these startups as well you got
understand these these are very exciting
companies and you know the height of
technology is what we use on a
day-to-day basis we play with games we
use apps you know these are very
exciting opportunities for a lot of
people to get experience and from what I
understand the experience they gain is
invaluable you know how do they pay
their rent it's difficult it's a
difficult question I mean fro from our
perspective I don't know how they pay
the rent but my respective we pay people
I mean I'm just what I'm just wondering
what kind of people you can attract in
the digital economy if you're not paying
I mean your company may be an exception
but generally there are a lot of unpaid
internships so who can afford to come
and work for you then these are gonna
have to be well-heeled young people who
have just come out of the university or
who are still studying but that's a
certain social class right i mean these
are upper class people who already have
money what happens to the middle class
in the lower class young people who want
to get a foot in the door I mean they
are blocked you know they're blocked
immediately aren't they well I think one
of the arguments I read in the guardian
article was that the that they were
based a lot of these tech companies were
looking you know we were siding with
universities and educational
institutions and basically there was
becoming a profit wagging you know these
these these universe they were hand
picking the best rich students out of
these universities and no one else was
getting a look in basically and that
probably certainly happens in in bay
area perhaps to some extent in London as
well but I think in Berlin and the parts
of Europe where I have experience in
that doesn't really happen and I think
it's just an accepted princess accepted
thing that you have to go for an
internship in order to step up the
ladder and you have to accept the fact
that you might not be paid brum what's
your experience I mean
you're a part of this of this new
economy what I mean what do you see do
you see a lot of people working for free
yeah but it's I don't think these people
that I know are not exploited by big
companies it's more that you as a
freelancer you have to do all the things
and most of the freelancers start from
what they like to do which is mostly
technological based kind of things to do
and then the whole finance side around
it is it's a bit more tricky yeah this
is my experiment want but why why is it
tricky though I mean if I go to work for
an established non new economy company I
know that I can go in and I can
negotiate and that I'm going to get at
least a decent salary why is it
different in the new economy what I mean
what's going on it isn't isn't everyone
drinking from this kool-aid and
believing that because everything on the
internet is open and free labor is also
going to be free I mean isn't that what
we're telling ourselves no I don't
believe that I mean I think I think
there are certain situations where that
is true but I think if you look at
talking generally speaking that's not
that's not a rule things on the internet
I mean a lot of these companies in the
insect don't make money at all right
they offer free products and they have
absolutely no way of monetizing it or
they don't have a good understanding of
how to monetize yeah you have a bunch of
25 year old geeks coming out of college
you know university who's starting up
their company for the first time and a
lot of them have very little if none no
business sense whatsoever they don't
understand how to monetize a platform
they can build something brilliant but
they don't have to monetize it and the
way I like to look at it but it's not an
excuse for not paying the people who
work for you that right well it depends
what you can afford pattering it really
depends if you can afford to pay people
to work for you or whether you sell them
the dream that we're building something
cool stick with us yeah but that's what
up that's what I say when I talk about
drinking from the same kool-aid yeah
that we're believing we're on somewhere
a part of something that's new and big
but at the end of the day you know our
bank accounts are you know there's a big
fat zero
everything do you think that there needs
to be some type of regulation but
possibly yeah I mean I think they're for
bigger companies that probably should be
some type of regulation I think for
example with with interns bringing three
people in they should be a limited
amount of time with what they can work
there should be a clear plan of how they
can proceed within the company so they
know from day one which direction
they're going yeah I think that's very
important as well I think also that
educational institutions could probably
do a lot more to prepare people for how
to work in this industry you know to how
to get ahead to how to network actually
using the tools that we're talking about
social networking tools yeah I mean I
don't know how you know your university
professor can prepare you to work for
free yeah I mean Oliver let me ask you I
mean you're our man from the Greens the
greens are the champions of the new
economy of you know the digital economy
these young workers is it is there a
role for the state for the government to
step in to make sure that this this new
age exploitation does not get worse SME
Vance should be the general rule but
people who are working get wages they
can support the laughs from that I think
that's essential that if owed a new
account Khan Academy that should be a
general rule but I think of the same
impression that there is always if there
is a new economy people are starting
very optimistic small companies and then
they work without getting money because
they expect a chance for the future life
and because of that they can be
exploited and i think it's it's a task
for the government for the for the state
in general to look on this is it a state
behind on this though I mean are these
developments aren't these things
happening so quickly that you guys just
can't keep up with it certainly it's
it's not always possible because we have
very many small companies and two it's
it's it's impossible and its reunion
there's no trade union for the civil
rights I think there will be a
development in the future as we saw it
in the past already in other parts of
the economic that if the companies get
bigger than the trade unions and the
organization
like a bit website in Germany they will
come out there and they will organize it
and there will be chance but I think
it's one important point you already
said there is a general discussion of
general feeling internet is all free and
this will be at least a part of the
economic problem to pay the people yeah
because I look for example I look at my
son is always says everything has to be
free on the internet and but I say you
guy there there should be people who
make it who have to spend the hours to
develop it and certainly they have to be
paid and is it are in aren't we guilty
ourselves is that I mean we go on the
internet I mean I you know I did tons of
research there's tons of things written
about new economy worker exploitation
here I mean it's like a mountain but we
go on the internet and expect to get all
this information for free so there's a
price to be paid for getting stuff
that's free isn't there and I mean how
can I get all this information for free
if the people producing it are going to
be paid so aren't the consumers at the
end of the day aren't we responsible for
the exploitation that's happening no no
I mean you if you all right first of all
give me give me can you give me an
example what you mean by something free
give me example well I mean let's say I
mean we're running out of time but let's
make it brief you know let's say you go
on you do a search on Google you want to
look up you know digital economy worker
exploitation tons of articles are
written there you have access to them I
didn't have to pay a dime for any of
these articles now these articles are
all works of journalists yeah they're
not receiving a dime for form for me
having access to that isn't that wrong
that is yeah i mean i thought i think
that is wrong these are not the people
that I work with on a day-to-day basis
so i can't speak for them or how much
they get paid until I brought you in
because you're a good guy Jerry you like
you have to confess that but I think no
I think that is that is wrong I mean the
people we work with other tech guys and
the product guys and they get paid a
great deal for specialists yes the
specialists all right there they're not
the creative guys yeah this is yeah
something we could talk about I'm sure
we'll be talking about
us again in the near future because the
whole issue with representation and
trade unions that is a chapter that has
yet to be written but let's move on we
want to go to something that gets more
towards to the core talking about money
that is fracking now fracking is
politically radioactive here in Germany
the government has tabled any discussion
on a fracking law until after the
national election in September our
politicians here tuning out the rest of
the world the International Energy
Agency says that we are in a golden age
of natural gas in that of countries move
forward with fracking carefully energy
prices will fall jobs will be created
and the reliance on fossil fuels from
unstable regions such as the Middle East
could be over within a decade in the US
a fracking boom is under way the
technology has led to a leap in
production of oil and gas pushing down
prices at home and boosting the
country's exports but not everyone's
happy critics say fracking is dangerous
and bad for the environment
it involves using fluids to break up the
ground to get at the gas and oil
underneath there are worries that can
lead to gas leaks contamination even
earthquakes concerns like these are one
reason Europe is lagging a long way
behind the u.s. in Poland and the UK
drilling is at an exploratory stage but
France has banned fracking in Germany
politicians have decided to put off a
decision to allow it on a commercial
scale until after elections in September
Oliver what happens after the election
is it going to be yes or no to fracking
I think it will be no because fracking
is no solution for Germany and I see a
big majority in parliament especially
from the left side of the permit but
also in the conservative side of the
Parliament that they don't want fracking
because it's no solution for our energy
but let's talk about why it's no
solution for Germany the Americans are
going full steam ahead with it and they
expect to be energy independent by the
end of this decade I mean that has to be
a role model for Germany yes but the
u.s. is the only country in the world
was it doing now at the moment and you
have to look on European geology it's
quite different from the US our reserves
are much lower as mining experts tell us
so there will near there if also if we
will say yes we do fracking and we go on
there won't be such a boom at in the US
and certainly there are many signs that
the u.s. boom is a very short-term boom
and we are not sure I mean I don't know
about that now I mean if we look at the
numbers the international energy agency
they are 2012 reports come out and
they're talking about this golden age of
natural gas the United States is about
to become an exporter of natural gas
Germans are paying seven times more for
natural gas right now than Americans are
paying I mean how do you tell your
voters how do you explain your vote
your voters that Americans have this
incredibly cheap natural gas but you
have to buy from the Russians and you
have to pay a premium of seven times
what the Americans pay energy was always
cheaper the US and in Europe that sets
no no phenomenal fracking and I have to
tell my my voter than the people living
in Germany and that the reserves we have
in in the soil of Germany is so low that
it's no game changer if we take all
everything out with all the risk of
pollution and so on with even
earthquakes with climate questions it
wouldn't change German energy prices our
mining companies themselves say this
Germany's it's only a question to get
some a little amount of gas reform the
soil and the risk and the costs of the
pollution is in our eyes it's much
higher this was to take it so let's say
then okay the geology in Germany is not
ideal let's let's assume that that's
true you're still obviously looking for
ways to lower energy costs for people in
Germany the United States is probably by
the end of this decade will be able to
export liquefied natural gas all over
the world is Germany going to be one of
the first customers to buy that and I
think we all its Germany's a country
which has to import gas in the next
decades that certainly offers but I
don't believe that we will import guess
from the US and I will I'm not sure if
the development in the international
energy agency said rods for example the
energy watch group another international
group of other experts says it will be a
very short term and they don't believe
that the US and the enter will export a
huge amount of gas and so I don't see
this development that they will come
gasps from the u.s. to Europe certainly
there is a much guess from other
countries from Norway from Qatar from
from
on the European market and there there's
enough supply for us payable supply so
as a competition okay so how do you tell
your voters that you're going to push a
policy that says we'd rather buy from
Russia or Qatar or Saudi Arabia when
you've got the United States a an ally a
peaceful a lie that's willing to sell
you natural gas below the price that
you're going to get from the Russians
yes I mean I mean I don't I don't see it
at the moment it's it's unreal
discussion that we import from the US
the discussion in Germany is how to take
gas out of the German salt that the
discussion at the moment and as you said
you sure they're not going to have that
right nearly all European countries as
France s Sweden of the Netherlands most
countries say we don't we have we are
very we are not optimistic we don't
believe in this technology so then that
is a discussion at the moment I it's
it's a decision of the u.s. to go to
make their own energy politics that's
certainly okay if they export not now
they are not doing it it's only I think
my opinion into wish other people say it
will be the future but if they do it and
then it's a new discussion certainly but
German I'm asking you what did the
Greens say about that I mean that's an
interesting proposition isn't it Oliver
if the United States can sell natural
gas to you you no longer have to buy
from the Russians the Russians use
energy as a political weapon now common
sense would tell you it would be better
to buy from Uncle Sam than to buy from
the Kremlin the most amount of guests we
buy is from the Netherlands and it's
from Norway in Germany and so I don't
see that these countries use that as a
political weapon or if Russia uses at a
political up to Germany I didn't get
that it is digital several winters where
they have turned delivery of oil off and
it has impacted the reserves in Germany
it's happened at least twice I mean even
your party
has come out and said that they are
alarmed by how Russia uses the energy
card I mean my question is that we are
looking on the general development we
are talking about years and decades yeah
and our it's our our task as greens as
it is the general decision in Germany to
to ban all fossil energies and to come
to renewable that's the most us and we
have talked about the fact that we can
produce our energy from our own from a
nubile energies and think that is the
most important factors of the most
important think we have to talk about
certainly if you import fossil energy
from any country of the world there
there are impacts negative impacts as we
take it from from the US it's as impact
of fracking if we import it from Russia
you can say that's no democratic state
and so on so we have decided to produce
our energy from our own as renewables
and that's that's the most important
what do you say about the the
international energy agency says the
good news about about fracking is that
the risks are manageable that if
companies and states follow a list of
golden rules for this Golden Age
consumers can count on safe cheaper
energy I mean the you know the IAEA is
saying that the iod ism an institution
that negotiates and the pastor that
there will be any problems with fossil
energies they didn't even talk about
renewables in the pasta I they gave many
advisors which were wrong which showed
wrong in the past they change their
opinion to a nuclear energy in the last
so I read this was with interesting eyes
but it's not a Bible for me and if i see
i went to the u.s. to pennsylvania and
looked there what's going on was
freaking and i met many people there
who say oh that's it's no good decision
as maybe they're the majority in the US
population who says it's okay we do we
we go this way but I also see that there
are many people who say that the wrong
way that we should go another way and
watch what is happening in the u.s. that
they are developed the technology
learning by doing and by this they
produce polluted ground they pollute
they produce polluted landscape and I
think this is the wrong way it's it's
not okay to to use our environment as a
test field fight for such a tenor okay
well Germany is getting out of nuclear
power but during the transition I mean
you say the goal is to have a hundred
percent renewable energy sources but in
order to get to that point there most of
the energy companies are in agreement
that Germany will have to import
electricity at some time it may come
from France which generates eighty
percent of its electricity with nuclear
power hour are you as a member of the
Green Party are you willing to say that
along the way to getting to a hundred
percent renewables it is okay to tap
into energy sources that we are against
it's a fairy tale that we have to import
energy from France from nuclear power
it's it's quite the opposite Germany is
exporting electra electric energy in in
many other countries of Europe we
produce much more electricity than we
use in Germany because of the
development of the little transition to
renewables is not going to be a problem
if we are tracking it they have to be
they have to it has to be a frame that
we are working on there many discussions
there are certainly problem but the
development is going on for example 10
years ago we had four percent renewables
in the energy system now we have
twenty-five percent nobody nobody in
German expected this development there
were many groups for example like the
EAA it's was one group who said it's not
possible for Germany to get
more than four or five percent now we
have twenty-five percent and the
development goes on we have to see it we
have to manage it it's a complicated
process but I don't see the development
that we have to import nuclear
electricity from frost for example it's
in the last winter's it was quite
opposite Ronnie exported and equation
right over have to wrap up I'm going to
bring you back on the show a year from
now and we're going to look at the the
transition and we're going to see it
what the import of energy picture what
that looks like anyway we have to move
on and we want to talk about something
that requires energy and the question is
are we about to witness the end of the
manufacturing economy I wonder if that
could go hand in hand with all the
renewables will factor is one day be a
ghost of the first Industrial Revolution
now that could very well be the case if
you believe in the potential of 3d
printing imagine having a printer at
home that can basically print anything
that you have the blueprint for
furniture appliances even medication
well the technology is already here is
still has a ways to go but it has
already made a big bang literally 3d
printers have been hailed as a
revolution in manufacturing the
technology allows objects to be printed
layer by layer usually using plastic
it's also possible to print with rubber
glass and ceramics initially expensive
3d printers are getting cheaper thanks
to technology it's possible to download
designs from the internet and produce
objects at home instead of buying them
recently it stirred controversy when an
American designed and printed a gun so
what does the future hold for 3d
printing will it revolutionize the
economy and pave the way for a second
industrial revolution or is it all just
hiding yeah what do you say brom is it
all just a bunch of hype I mean you're a
3d man no I don't think it's all just a
bunch of hype but i think is not really
understood completely by the media and
some some people write a bit too
optimistically about it him where are we
where are we too optimistic it is it is
a you should understand 3d printing is a
very flexible and versatile way of
manufacturing things it is a rather not
a very efficient way of producing things
so if you want to have many of the same
things it is much better to use
traditional methods like injection
molding where you want to have something
but and that's like that's like what we
need a factory for today right right
we're not talking about a printer at
home right but what could we use right
now I mean what things do we need that
we could print at home right now I mean
you brought sin dunno yeah show us what
you brought in today man get that unless
we get it's basically and 3d printers
all right I mean so this is why this is
like a cup or a flower this is a cup or
a vase or a candle holder I someone
design it I downloaded it from the
internet I printed it same for this
chain and you can do some funny tricks I
chose that because I mean a lot of
people were saying we could use this as
Mardi Gras as a necklace I mean what do
you think about this if it were green
Oliver would you wear it green with we
better caliphate but that's a credit in
green you can print it agree okay and
tell me the about your penguin here yeah
it is i made a little penguin and I
printed it and so that is its it's
rather complex shapes you can do
interesting things it's actually very
heavy I mean it's not I mean if people
think it you know you're printing
something there's no paper here right I
mean this is hard plastic but it's
biodegradable plastic it's PLA so it's
not made out of oil it's not synthetic
it's made out of corn or corn rests of
corn and then fermented in and turns
into this plastic you said you
downloaded all this from the internet
yes is the internet the key to the
success of 3d printing it is because
objects become more and more digital so
it requires no labor or special skills
to make an exact copy this of this
in say New York I can just email it to
someone in new york or the the guy
downloads it and on his printer or her
printer prints the same thing did you
have to pay for the blueprints for any
of these no it is mainly hobbyist who do
it so it's not exploitation if you're
going to that direction it is well my
question is if you were to walk into a
store and buy and see this you would
have to pay for it but you didn't pay
for this you printed it at home I design
it myself but if I also voted on the
internet and if you put things on the
internet you can attach a Creative
Commons license to its for example if I
would have okay my opinion for example I
can say okay you can print for your own
use but you cannot make a business out
of it it's like a Creative Commons
license if there is there any way like
is there any way to you know protect
intellectual property copyrights on on
on products does 3d printing threaten
you know the legal protections that we
have now not so much yet because 3d
printing is also a way of making things
and it has different rules as other ways
of making things and it's kind of
difficult for example if I would like to
steal the intellectual property of this
glass to exactly produce it on my 3d
printer it will change a bit more if
products are more designed for 3d
printing which is not the case yet our
still this is may designed for for glass
manufacturing which is a big factory
where you can do different things as on
your 3d printer but there is it possible
it's possible right now though to go
onto the internet and to find the
blueprint for certain things to download
that and and to print them correct and
there are a lot of things that are free
as this technology advances do you see
though a dilemma let's say let's say I
do want to print this glass and the
technology is there what is going to
prevent me from printing this glass
without paying for it
difficult still yeah okay you can print
glass that's true it's still pretty
expensive machines so more for
industrial use and if there is not so
much of preventing it it's the saying
the wild west of the internet that we've
been talking about earlier is the same
thing it's it's also with the same
problem with music and movies it's it's
pretty difficult to stop what do you say
about this I mean this is very
disruptive isn't it this is what this
could turn manufacturing on its head
couldn't it I mean it could I mean I
don't know where we are with
capabilities of these princes yet and I
don't know what materials I'm assuming
it's just plastic so you can use and not
is it basically just plastics yeah at
home and i'm not sure how long it will
take to get to the point where we can
actually sit at home and make whatever
we want you know I fancied donut or a
glass or something like that and you can
just print it out like this you know but
yeah I mean there could be a problem but
you know you could also provide a link
to a paypal account as I don't think
won't pay for it what I'm thinking too
yeah and you know Oliver let me ask you
what would what role does the state have
in all of this there's there has to be
some type of regulation right i mean you
could put in theory you could put all
types of of companies out of business
with this technology you need to i think
if i stand it right you need to some
blueprints you need to the program to
get from the internet and so we have the
regulation that you have to pay for the
program and send certainly it's a it's
an opportunity the possibility to
produce it by the sweetie printer of
your own and I think that's the next
step of industrial production if you
only take the blueprint pay for it and
then you can use it as you want I think
that's a development you can stop in the
end okay you know we're running out of
time Robert tell us how long did it take
the printer to actually make this when
it started printing something like 12
hours or so 12 hours oh that's a long
time I don't have
work for it I usually have my printer
running overnight to produce stuff for
my workshops in building 3d printers
many of the plastic parts are also are
produced by 3d printers as well so it is
it's quite a time demanding process but
it's it doesn't require a labor because
it's just a computer executing all the
right so there's no one there's no one
manufacturing this exactly and that's
also the hope of I mean the Chinese for
example I mean they have to be worried
about this right the factory of the
world they're not going to be needed
anymore if we if we're all able to do
this at really diving into 3d printing
they they really put a lot of innovation
capacity into 3d printing there's no
advanced enough to write you called me a
threat yeah it was I mean we're all kind
of sitting here as standard by this but
I mean I know a lot of people are
writing on this they're sounding the
alarm and they're calling on people like
you Oliver to step in to make sure this
doesn't get out of control it is our
politicians going to be able to make
sure that this does not destroy the
manufacturing world as we know it as I
give it at the moment as I said if I
stand it right it's only by plastic so
you get to only syncs you get to in a 1
euro shop for example yeah and it's
certainly certainly more expensive to
produce this 12 hours by your 3d print
printer then go in a 1 euro shop and buy
it from Chinese kenwood from a company
with as produce it in yeah in China so I
think it would it will depend on
the development if there are other
products other materials inside this
thing we have to wrap it up anyway we'll
see I mean maybe we can sell this at the
next Mardi Gras see how much money we
can make with it Rob gentlemen thank you
very much for being on the show that's
going to wrap up my agenda this week
don't forget that you can watch the show
again on our website and on YouTube and
don't be shy tell us what you think our
inbox is always open I'm Brent Gogh in
Berlin and join me next time when i set
the agenda
you